flights camera dink dink donk dink donk
dink donk donk welcome back to the Jenna
Jillian podcaster anchors taped I
sprained my pinky you sprained it it's
brain did it almost broke it really
hurts oh my god
welcome to the Jenna julia podcast
julian has sprained fingers yeah buddy
taped them together buddy to buddy since
night ah thank you guys for joining us
for another episode of the genuine
podcast this episode is brought to you
by i bowl and branch get some of the
softest bedding duvet covers towels
scarves yes from Bolin branch guys
Bowlin branch cuts out the middleman
they ship it directly to your house and
they are a great company that fights
human trafficking they literally take
proceeds of their sales and put it
towards fighting human trafficking great
cause great company great people and
obviously a great product for the
fraction of the cost of other bedding
and luxury softness out there so go to
Bowlin branch calm right now and type in
Jenna Julianne as your products code for
20% off your purchase also brought to
you by me undies me on these some of the
dopest underwear out there in the game
right now this is some of it right here
sweet ass designs micro modal fabric
which is twice as soft as cotton guys
that is no joke you wear that on your
fly it is legit that was on my butt
except it's clean I cleaned it for this
go to meet undies comm / Jenna Julian
for 20% off your purchase guys me Andes
is sick ball and ranch is sick thank you
to our sponsor thank you sponsors on
Belle ba on the blog I'm wearing a scarf
how I look warm in the neck I am one in
the neck well I'm so happy for you I'm
happy for me too
yeah to be look as if it yeah it matches
yeah it does you look great today I'll
say that you look wonderful
Thanks you're welcome well we are back
up in this podcast room to do some
podcasts in about what are you asked
yeah you're supposed to like come in
like this is Wow okay well it was a
suggestion on Twitter it was
at like the verb Mallory washing asked
us for one of your podcast
you all should create real slogans for
brand / products and then tweeted us
this picture that said Pepsi is Pepsi
okay which we thought was really funny
because roll we control again there's a
lot of room for funny jokes and
discussions in there
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take we actually prepare this you
know beforehand but Jen and I are gonna
take our lists of brands and we're going
to give you what we think is a trolli or
an honest slogan yeah that we would make
for the brand based on what we feel like
the brand gives you fun done as a
customer yes for fun times because this
podcast is about fun it's about talking
and but it's mainly about the fun
Wow good Center thank you I don't know
where I was in the middle but I finished
I got there so lady in the beautiful
white hat yeah may go first
yeah yeah that's right good my first one
is Sephora makeups Narnia makeups Narnia
I also wrote come with your wallet leave
without any money left say goodbye to
your boyfriend and your afternoon and
that's all it's all accurate makeups
narnia it's pretty right now yeah they
just have a closet door as the front
door right to Sephora any walk in and
they're gone for the lion and snow and
you think you've been gone for like an
hour but you've been gone for like six
days my god that's horrible
United being in a Sephora for six days
Julian that's your hell that's you're
definitely not done that yet what have
we not been there for six days in the
room I feel like we have Wow no that was
like 10 minutes Wow Wow
Julian see that's why it's Narnia your
time is reversed exactly
you're you're 10 minutes feels like six
days and my six days would feel like I
mean boyfriend's am i right out there
girlfriends are right out there sitting
in Sephora holding that [ __ ] little
mesh thing you will ever have to hold
the bag I always have to hold the bag I
think that he secretly likes doing that
I don't I don't I don't even at the
shittiest of malls I'd rather be in any
other store especially because and this
is great because there's gonna help but
like they asked 50 people asking for if
they you need help like no I'm just
holding a bag so you don't even need to
talk to me ask her but she doesn't need
help but they really do there's so many
employees in there there are a lot of
employees it's crazy man
that's probably my dream job you'd be so
good at it
it would mock what Tommy did you want to
buy this because if I don't because I'm
you get on here by the way guys oh he's
he's wanting to his beard he shaved his
beard because just sort of like trimmed
it I didn't shave it to the skin I did
like a deep mantle I got what squat I go
like a nice little shape I feel so much
better you do it was bugging me less hot
in the face let's hide the face that's
it she in the face yeah mm-hmm you like
had grown it out nice with your beard
oil and brush I did I can condition it I
watch them broken he's been brushing his
beard I wasn't fooling anyone I
literally logged it I feel fooled
deceived I feel the same on two Apple
Apple one no oh yeah Apple we probably
don't need a slogan you'll buy it anyway
oh it's too real it's too [ __ ] real
that's good right yeah it is good yes
Wow
all right Starbucks first world coffee I
have a Starbucks one day that's nice
your Starbucks what Starbucks [ __ ] your
name wow that's really good okay so for
those of you that know who Rome is her
name is Rome Australian Rome like the
city in Italy Rome and so she goes Rome
sort of like says like that as a
horrible impression yeah so she has a
weird name and a weird accent it's not
weird it's a drum realm yeah but when
she says it
it sounds rim to be fair it's a pretty
short name so they should be on it so
let's tell them what some of the names
that they give her arm arm was my arm
they literally wrote arm
a RM arm or Warren Warren Warren Warren
I run run run I call her like all three
of those names top arm salon hmm
thanks a lot arm thanks arm thanks arm
bomb
thanks Rome bomb Rome Rome bomb Rome
Bhama or o bomb rome wasn't good enough
it had to be Rome bomb Rome oh my
goodness all right lays like the chip
company lays lays we like to look at the
bag half-full
Wow cuz they leave like half the bag
full
oh boy waiver it's so true though it's
so frustrating when you're like getting
all excited because I really like salt
and vinegar chips yeah they're really
[ __ ] good no tank they're dank s bomb
ass day guys bomb ass jeans and the bag
is like half full of chips so they like
to look at the bag half full not the
Glock okay but like even okay if you buy
a big size one it's not as bad no it's
only it's another small ones so little
one little one like $0.99 bag of look
you just want something bigger
there's never you never know because
they're all my chips yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] man why is that uh you know I
don't know they like to look at the bag
half full so I know you're looking at
half empty but they like to look at it
as half full it's not your face is
twitching stop doing there could be face
mm-hmm all right I got one ready yeah
Victoria's Secret let us measure you
even though you've had breasts for over
a decade every time I go in there if you
start looking at a bra they're like oh
do you need to get measured I'm like
[ __ ] does it look like I need to get do
I look like I woke up with these titties
is all you say they just are on say like
some of them and they're just assumed
that you're like an idiot and then that
you don't know what your bra size sizes
how can I not know what my bra size is
to be fair they are experts no not
you're right they're not they're not at
all oh my god they make me frustrated
though too
I like their sterling I'm not gonna lie
those drawers it feels like you're in a
big closet you just open the drawer and
you take the underwear that you I mean
that sounds creepy I'm not in there
alone but no it's a cool layout like
you're like oh what sighs all right
let's go to the third drawer down yeah
it saves a lot of space - is it nice but
yeah that's [ __ ] so I'm just like
I've given into the oh do you need to
get measured thing a couple of times and
they should go you're nice I am I feel
bad yeah but they're probably bored at
work I just want to measure some teddies
anyways but like thank you alone of all
people like if I go to the mall
chances are I'm probably wearing like a
sports bra and they'll measure you and
be like oh you're like
34a and I'm like [ __ ] don't you know
I'm wearing like a compression bra right
now like that's not the size of my boobs
this is why I don't want to get measured
because you're wrong you should know
that's what happens when you wear a
sports bra and they don't care then
they're like here let me pull some bras
for you I'm like please don't cuz that
shit's not gonna fit on my titties
mmm-hmm Teddy's Teddy's this is a
passionate issue for you art that's not
it does epistles meow hmm I'm sorry like
shouldn't I be the one to measure my own
boobs you know you should do with a
measuring tape you need a way I don't
have a sports but this is what we need
to next time we go to Victoria Secret
just bring a measuring table when they
say can we measure you be like only if I
can measure you I'm not a start
measuring that's actually a good idea we
should do it mmm I like since when are
you certified as an employee of
Victoria's Secret to touch my boobies
with your hands this feels like the
girls ooh I didn't open the grub seal
for you this feels like the grubs ooh
mmm I don't like that Oh Tori a secret
the grubs it is open all right that's a
good slogan I was good swing high go
ahead sorry I digress
yeah now that's that's good all right
Slim Jim have a good road trip oh it's
too though yeah everybody's eating like
that's when you eat a slim jim
just like when you're traveling every
road trip that's what it should say on
the slim jim oh that's cute though if it
did say that they just want you to have
a good road trip I've good one
oh you know while you drive it's
one-handed I love functions I like when
if you're eating can you eat slim jims
you can't I cannot eat slim jims I don't
know why I said loves limbs but I love
those pepperoni sticks made by [ __ ]
don't even like the same but the slim
jims I cannot hate because it has no um
my favorite is when Julian's eating a
beef stick of some kind or a turkey and
like our I've done this in the past when
I used it eat beef sticks you'd like
take a bite and then the color like that
and feed it to the dogs like oh yeah
like a bird yeah cuz you can't just like
let him bite it you got a bite off we're
cousins
but you don't put it straight in their
mouth no I got it
I like spitting in their throat Biggie's
go oh my god cause I'm not marbles
though he refuses to see but no he
buries it he's too scared in the car
what you got next client um Bob's Red
Mill get frustrated by our bags oh
that's true hey they're a great company
but yeah their bags like how am I
supposed to open them and not spill it
all over the place it's so frustrating
like the only reason that they have
those bags has to be like to keep their
costs down or something well it could
have something to do with the
preservation of gluten-free products
being in a smaller bag that might be
something to do with maybe not it
doesn't have to be a frustrating bag no
that doesn't excuse that you could make
a little zip locks at the top it's look
for those of you that know ABAB
dreadmill is there like you know in your
baking aisle or whatever they give you
these like the size of a brick of
cocaine it's like in the movies outside
of us it looks like that yeah but like
yeah they're just little bags so then
once you cut it open like unless you get
a rubber band and then you [ __ ] but
as you go through the bag
yeah you can no longer tell what product
is what product yeah because it's all
cause it's all rolled up yeah and it's
like say you open a brand-new bag and
you take a little bit off when you're
rolling it up it just spits out flour as
you tie it up yes it's such a there's so
little room to actually fold but we have
like a lot of Bob's Red Mill because
they make a lot of gluten free stuff
yeah I know it I finally talked drooling
into getting those like plastic storage
containers because you we have so many
of those little [ __ ] bags we can't
tell what's whatever you do yeah nobody
happen let's get some glass mason jars
yeah you want to do tonight
yeah great can we run to the store real
quick all right hold on I gotta go get
some mason BRE
okay all right boo boo
the guy from Shark Tank still likes to
talk about us for some reason oh my god
I [ __ ] fired
Wow but it's FUBU wow I am still like
yeah like it's FUBU like that's a big
deal but why are you so like touted its
FUBU wow wow wow wow ok ok
for anyone that watches Shark Tank the
creator of boo boo Damon Damon Johnson
right John
is it Johnson Damon Damon whatever Damon
he's on there and leaving the rock jam
when they do like their intros they tell
like who's who and I'm sorry I just I'm
feeling good yeah I'm sure you know I'm
going but they say like who's who and
how they made their millions of dollars
and why they're here like investing and
stuff and so I was like Damon who the
creator of FUBU and and Julian just
starts like dying laughing every time
he's like dude nobody buys FUBU anymore
like why are you sold again I get that
but I was also laughing because uh
whenever we're watching Shark Tank we
always left because Robert always
getting through Robert gets [ __ ] every
episode he like he tries so hard to like
develop a rapport with the person who's
pitching and he's so nice and he always
ends up trying to give a deal but then
he gets like outbid or like teamed up on
and it's just like poor Robert like none
of the participants ever pick yeah never
pick him even when he's got a great deal
they like choose other people with the
same deal like one of the Sharks will
take his deal and then make it their
deal yeah the person would be like done
deal and then it's like but it's and
then it cuts to his face and he's always
just like it was God the Michael Jordan
face on he like perpetuates it though
because he he's like he gets he's a
little bit petulant he like it's
offended by things eggwin when people
ask him questions or when one of the
other sharks like throws a little jab at
him he'll like really get sad and it's
like wait dude you got it like have
thicker skin you're you're a shark like
he's so sweet John some some skank
Julian will just start cracking up well
because it happens every episode like
every single time so funny ah well you
know at least Daymond created FUBU
that's I'm saying like
is dope 15 years ago what like what
happened it's it sounds like Sean John
yeah it's exactly like Sean John it's
like I feel so bad for people that Judy
ever burnt Von Dutch like that fashion
changes it's what you asked for a couple
these like really popular brands they
like it really popular and then all of a
sudden everyone's like yeah we not win
away that anymore
remember those [ __ ] trucker hats you
work so cool if you had a Von Dutch I
had a pair of Von Dutch jeans that had
like thin like a giant embroidered like
patch on the back when said Von Dutch
and but they were beautiful jeans and I
had them for [ __ ] years and they were
awesome I loved them
I'm not positive I have to verify this
in my mom or something or my journal and
you keep a journal but I'm pretty sure I
had a fake Von Dutch hat they say cute
you sleep yeah like at some point you
have to stop wearing it because people
are let do you sugata trends just go
away and it looks like it's crazy that
that that happens that way but that's
how it is like it was so cool and now
it's so not ruthless ruthless savage
savage and savage a half girl where you
got a next girl okay KFC chicken we
think question odds brutal brutal Mars
man brutal Mars Wow if you don't like my
puns get out of the pun kitchen Wow
podcaster just B's called Wow
oh by the way I have in one of my tag
lines there's one office quote and you
have to guess which one it is but I do
know I can't even believe that anybody
watched or listened to our podcast last
week so I'm talking about Pham that's
ridiculous
it was just me like being frustrated you
living I was living I was living as dope
Oleg is amazing Oh target almost as fun
as Disneyland at like a third of the
price oh that's actually true I think I
had a target one too
do you want to hear my target one target
oh we can't go to Walmart
it's okay but target is like a fun place
to be
it's like I just like don't like when we
want the shame just to just go kill time
go [ __ ] look around yeah sing some
music walk around when I was hanging out
with him before we made a video and we
went to like Toys R Us and targeter I
think we went to a bunch of places that
he went to Toys R Us huh yeah and he was
like let's just go get a PP and I was
like what the [ __ ] is a PP he's like a
pointless purchase then you go oh my god
something stupid and then you'll get
like that's me inspired by just being in
an environment with lots of things
you've never seen before
yeah target is great for pts distresses
pointless iYou know what chain is me I
am Shan Shan is the letter le let me
okay so my next one I don't want anyone
to get offended by I'm offended alright
if you attend this specific institution
don't be offended by this because I joke
and I have plenty of friends who go
there but it's well known that this is
the thing so here it is Planet Fitness
no dead lives allowed but pizza parties
every Friday because because they don't
allow deadlifts and that's my favorite
lift of all time they don't allow they
literally don't allow deadlifts if they
see you doing deadlifts I've seen plenty
of stories all over mostly the fitness
subreddit but a lot of places on the
inner you cannot do deadlifts at Planet
Fitness even if you're not hitting the
weight hard on the ground why it's a
judgment-free zone it's too boisterous I
don't know they have their reasons but
yeah I mean once you don't allow
deadlift you're not a gym oh oh [ __ ] oh
yeah so that's why I'm that's why I'm
making that joke cuz I mean maybe they
do now but I know that they are I'm
saying with the bar if you did it with
like free weights you deadlift like
dumbbells yeah after not touching the
floor but they don't want weight
touching the floor I don't know I don't
know the reasoning I don't know the the
exact rules and I also know that they do
have pizza parties at Planet Fitness
that makes no sense yeah I mean like I
said I'm not judging if you go there
that's cool I heard a lot of people you
know a lot of friends out and go there
and still plays for everybody yeah I
need to be doing my deadlifts and also
like it's a weird principle to like ban
a certain lift because and I feel like
it's directly tied to their like
judgment-free zone thing like they just
assume everyone doing a deadlift is just
a [ __ ] troglodyte throwing weights
all over the place when really it's like
it's a great exercise yeah with the bar
and the weights touch the ground and you
can do them quietly without offending
anyone yeah oh you know what I bet if I
went in there and did some quiet
deadlifts maybe someone that wouldn't
say anything to me but if you went in
there and put five [ __ ] plates on
both sides and started doing deadlifts
you would get kicked out so fast I mean
are you intimidated don't mean just
because you do it heavier deadlift that
you would get in trouble and I wouldn't
that's strengthe strength this that's
totally strength astone lee because
you're doing your lifting too much
weight for to be a plant fitness yeah
that's a judgement yeah it's judgment
time you're supposed to be the judgment
free zone are we supposed to be able to
walk around in my underwear all over
Planet Fitness and not be judged
especially if it's Mandy's I'm supposed
to be able to come in that's me any dick
out and [ __ ] deathless what I want
dick out no shoes Ditka I will dick out
but and eat mousse on Friday mostly I
should be all the dead oh my me undies
and no like you missed it you missed it
you missed it I totally do that
transition and you were busy saying dick
knees I know you guys caught that I
don't have a dick but if I did it would
be in my me Andes oh you don't know
Wow never make that comment and that
noise back to back ever again guys got
me Andy's hottest underwear in the game
right now
everyone's got is seriously they come up
with new designs every month they have
different designers that come in and
design these really really cool pieces
for all their underwear and you can go
online and go to me on these calm and
see the selection it's really really
dope and once you wear your first pair
you understand what it means when it's
when they say it's micro model fabric
literally twice as soft as cotton you
don't understand what that means until
you put them on and you just feel
outstanding you're missing the whole
you're missing there it is
keep it go I can hear you okay yep so
guys check out me and he's go to me and
he's that's M e undies calm
/ Jana Julian get 20% off your first
order and then take a picture of your
underwear you don't take a picture of
your cellphone or maybe just a picture
on the table and tweet us because we
love when you guys do that that is
awesome
also bull and branch guys I can't stress
enough how like amazing this company is
as a whole they really really put time
effort and their proceeds into fighting
human trafficking which is something
that it's a it's a problem that a lot of
people just don't like to think about
because it's so horrible right but me
I'm sorry
Borland branch really focuses on it
they're a mom-and-pop company they treat
their workers amazing and they have you
know products that they bring you high
quality at affordable prices and uh in
my opinion when you buy things from a
company half the time I'm buying
something from them and I'm thinking
about what the company stands for so if
company is if a company is great
customer service I'm proud to buy stuff
from them if they have a good image or
if they donate to a good charity I'm
proud to buy stuff on them it's not only
about the products by the experience and
Boleyn branch has that completely
covered I have a conscience they have a
conscience and they cut out the
middleman guys I don't know if you're
going still want to the store to buy
sheets but that's old news get it
shipped directly to your house cut out
the middleman with Bowl and branch check
it out right now see their selection go
to Bowl and branch comm enter product
code Jenna Julian and you get 20% off
and by the way those sheets are so soft
next-level butter net they're butter you
sleep in butter and you maybe you wake
up all greasy just kidding okay but uh
thank you to our sponsors sorry for done
missing the transition cuz I wasn't
waiting I wasn't finished letting Jenna
you're done telling her this bit anyway
mmm whose term it's mine I'm speaking of
which but not our bowl and branch sheets
which are forever saying on the bed but
the sheets that we got it the next place
that Bath and Beyond
doesn't beyond I paid a pretty penny for
those and they're not agent
you know your shoots are supposed to get
like softer when you wash them and you
know what a golem branch
yeah but are the ones that like I paid a
lot of money for cuz they're like the
high thread count or whatever like I
feel like not getting any [ __ ] softer
they're just getting Tanner
so Bed Bath & Beyond I should have just
gone to balloon brand is that they're
slow yeah yeah okay Bed Bath & Beyond
for all your needs and totally non needs
but once you're here what's this oh my
god what's that also Christopher Walken
one one time worked here remember that
and click yeah you got the click record
I'm doing a good office references don't
high-five me with that little [ __ ]
finger see little buddy fing go touch it
I'm gonna take them and I'm just gonna
squeeze them till you feel it you're
gonna hurt my hurt thing give it to me
I'm gonna bring my finger oh she loves
taking like the dogs arms and he does
this thing where you pretend so he's
like say this is not I gotta go
mmm and I pretend I'm very gonna make
that noise because I'm sick I'm too
aesthetic I like what you do it took my
because you just the lays there like
that's gonna cut up put a little wrist
lock on mm-hm
propel water still for some reason to
thing oh my god what's like the company
that makes that I think it's Gatorade
there's a gay day oh no I've saw it on
the Shelf recently and I'm like how the
[ __ ] is this still a thing yeah a
disgusting and if I'm gonna like if I'm
gonna really like take the plunge and
like sacrifice sugar and carbs for a
drink which I will sometime so there are
a lot of occasions where I love Gatorade
like intense types of workouts hangovers
I love Gator on but why would I why
would I go that far and then have
something tastes like propeller it's
just so that yeah if you have a hangover
and then you drink like a hickey oh my
god it brings the life back yeah it
makes you feel alive again and live
again
and then love engage and why that's why
you engaged to me engaged to me that's
great English are you ready for this
next one don't point at me okay
Home Depot we're open really late
because we know you underestimated your
project that's good that's like super
real I feel like so real I mean you
always run back for like two nuts and
bolts yeah [ __ ] hammer home depot
we're open late because we know you
didn't get any of the things that you
were supposed to get the first time also
we have toilets chill that should be
part I was in I thought we have minutes
please don't [ __ ] in our Florida's my
god that's [ __ ] speaking of [ __ ] hot
pockets
Wow r.i.p the roof of your mouth yeah
true diarrhea pocket is dead package is
Jim Gaffigan yeah did you notice that he
became the colonel and KFC he just they
just switched it yeah they just switched
again it was the other community yeah
yeah normal
okay so I don't know yeah so um I think
it's Norma Donald and it would they like
he was brand new but then they weren't
feeling it they got Jim Gaffigan so the
spot that they did was Jim Gaffigan you
know it's it's Norma Donald right and
then it cuts the Jim Gaffigan has the
colonel waking up and I say I had a bad
dream there was another Colonel
pretending to be me so meta so meta but
yeah I loved him Gavin lounge in his Hot
Pockets bit is very funny you should
check it out on YouTube sometime guys
dad packy David Packard yeah he's the
best
okay I got a Whole Foods grocery chop
like there's no tomorrow because you
definitely won't have any money left
when you leave mmm
they put they call a whole paycheck
people have your limp a jacket no Turk
yeah it's so real surreal you okay we've
talked about this in a podcast before
though about how on the west coast
because people don't have to deal with
whether or whatever because on the East
Coast you shop for like a week or two
weeks here
do a huge shop so it's not like unlikely
you'll go into a grocery store and wait
in line to check out with people with
like one car or if they have big family
of groceries and you just wait in line
that's what you do whereas here
everybody's just got like a thing of
flowers and like a loaf of bread and
like a bottle of wine and you're like
okay so in free bread yeah I never a
time when I was going to the grocery
store when like every single time I pull
up with a cart full of groceries
something like ah it's a lot of
groceries I'm like excuse you like does
known [ __ ] grocery shop here like
shut the [ __ ] up whole paycheck man and
everyone behind you with like their
thing of flowers and like an apple is
waiting they're like what do you grocery
shop alright this is clothes money
no no they go to the grocery store get
with Apple every day that's what it's
like here every day that's why you can't
find a parking spot and the Whole Foods
parking lot to be fair have you ever had
one of their fresh made sandwiches at
their deli its dank I have and I know
you have yeah they have Bloomfield red
Julian was going through this phase
where he really liked those sandwiches
so he would go buy a loaf of bread I was
right and then give it to the devas they
didn't have glia made no sense
they have no gluten-free bread at the
sandwich counter so he would buy a loaf
of bread still read it over to the
counter and ask them to make it but
whole paycheck yeah now that place is
it's off off the chain a little bit and
not the best way it's okay there's a sub
place in high school that I like to go
and I used to love BLT sandwiches but
they didn't have any bacon so I would
bring in as a Bock bag a bag full of
little bacon and can you make me a BLT
it's so that every time they would bring
it out they'd be like alright so I mean
I guess it's just a veggie sub because
you brought your own meet you IOM or
BYOB Bambino bring your own meet discuss
can you imagine getting away with that
with any other meat just like a raw
steak in your backpack your fanny bag
can you put the steak on like you did
you ride your bike here with the [ __ ]
wait what like a raw steak kebab and
your wallet I know in this
kissing uh kebab good um makes a couple
of mine chipotle nobody here actually
knows what a proper scoop is and at this
point they're very bad oh yeah I made
that one up I feel so bad needed it when
you're like starving at Chipotle waiting
in that line and then that girl is like
whoever serving you is just like looking
around talking to her friends yeah that
really always so just dress yeah and
then she just gives you that tiny little
scoop of chicken and then that tiny
little scoop of rice and I'm looking at
Julian's Bowl like we either need to
order three more bowls I mean to be fair
Chipotle it takes a [ __ ] delicious so
that's why I want more of it but it's
like yeah and sometimes it's arbitrary
to that's why I made that slogan like
know each you know no - so Paco - yeah
there's no quality control there's no
exactly there's no no - employees who
have the same exact scoop size and some
of the big guys will look at maybe like
you want chicken
all right here's [ __ ] loaded chicken
and girls but you know oh actually put
one too many pieces so I'm gonna
actually dig into your bowl and put it
back have you seen them [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] yes they pull that one where they
they go back and like refund themselves
the chicken every time someone Rhys
coops chicken back into the chicken a
part of Julian dies like a muscle fiber
snaps inside of it and dies died I will
never get it back I know I'm sorry it's
okay it's all good I'm really sorry
it's always so sad I'm sorry okay
Supercuts
sorry that'll be ten dollars I'm sorry
you shoulda said super cuts just [ __ ] me
up fam sorry our bad I love how it leads
with sorry that's good sorry fam sorry
Pam right hi Instagram what are links
it's true I can't get over I like um
Perez Hilton does it like every single
day he people do still post links in
description so Lincoln I'm like I
why did why are you doing that whoever
is doing that still why Instagram is not
on board with me maybe I was like
confused maybe I didn't have an update
or something I know that's what I
thought too because people still put
links in their [ __ ] description in
their comment section
Donny cuz it makes every what though so
you think to the literal point zero five
percent of people who are going to look
at that and remember that you are out on
go typing in their browser you can't
even hold down and copy no you have to
go into the comments and then do that so
it's like frustrating hey scram will
[ __ ] the links that bro
Instagram with a little bit okay lush
boom we're the bomb Wow alright I
appreciate that dad joke yeah what if
we're just lush boom boom goes the
dynamite no I like the one where the
bomb with a bomb cuz in case the boom
didn't do it for Unabomber gonna tell
you we're the Baja bout lush bang out
where the bomb you know like bang ow I
dunno what manga you know like Bango
Bango Bango Bango Bango
hey good um
Facebook what is copyright Wow sorry
that was those too easy I'm just a
[ __ ] reai skipped it I skipped it too
[ __ ] I never said Jamba Juice it's
healthy I think oh it's so true though
so true yeah it's just sugar the calf
that stuff is just like sugary fake
stuff yeah I mean yeah that's me I think
it's how it's like fruity he looks fresh
smells good there's grass on the wall
yeah I mean just ask your like your face
in your mouth the question when I go
home and use fruit and make a smoothie
does it taste like this not really not
just sugar man okay um I got a funny one
coming
Davy's are us ah you thought you didn't
want a baby right now
every time we walk anywhere near a
Babies R Us jenna is inappropriate then
oh let's go to babies r us when we're in
there though cuz we shop for my niece
sometime when she was a baby
um you go in there and
everything is just so [ __ ] she's
you're right you're right Tommy it's
pretty [ __ ] cute right Marga a lot
it's really cute I mean you being
inappropriate in the sense of like we
went in here's one time we went into a
Babies R Us and every eye we worked on
Julian jesse was like Julian look at
this Julian put a baby that was a half
joke plan I'm like saying it to be
outrageously inappropriate I know it's
funny but yeah if things are very cute
there it is funny being outrageously
inappropriate is funny it is funny it is
it is mmm outrageously outrageously in
Jenna and Jen appropriate injection Java
Barrett Brooklyn carpet good in a
podcast pre it uber we can't wait to
have a conversation it's like therapy
for night drivers yeah you'd be the
therapist will drive you give you a
therapist yeah boy are we gonna exploit
uber we hate silence oxhorn
talk chat coffee hang up gum gum gum
anyone water doesn't gonna um
yeah which later on uh Yankee Candle
come get a headache with us like is your
smelly smelly mouth never leave you
candle or like go in there and you're in
there for too long and there you start
to get a headache from all the smell no
because when I guess that point I just
like walk away and you stay there it
like makes you a little nauseous yeah I
can see that yeah no Bath & Body Works
says that - there's like way too many
scents happening yeah makes you look
good it
why did go there then yeah well
sometimes I like candles thing is they
sometimes like being nauseous I don't go
there to throw up on the ground yeah
Pinkberry I can't believe this doesn't
have any calories
they do kind of like make it seem like
you're eating something really help yeah
it's not it's not I can't believe it's
not color you can eat a lot worse thing
that's true now if you get if you get
like the non-dairy the sherbert ones you
get those are just fruit but usually
really frozen yogurt places no I'm
talking about Pinkberry they have that
one you can have the non mellow the
girls cannot melt yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't think that's that bad for you no
it was more just a joke creepy okay
anyways um LensCrafters
stop please stop gluing your glasses
together very not exactly right okay I
went to the eye doctor I got a full
year's worth of contacts cuz I got an
eye exam my eyes have not changed my
prescription is exactly the same exactly
the same and I was like why did we even
do this [ __ ] told you honestly while
I was sitting there getting my eyes like
looked at and stuff I was like what is
the point of this like what did they
care what glasses or contacts I wear
like if I want to order they craft the
lenses they care no but like you can go
to the grill just hear me out or was it
you can go to the grocery store and buy
one of those you know five dollar pair
of reading glasses that make you feel
like you're in a [ __ ] Twilight Zone
because they're so intense you can buy
those off the rack but you cannot buy
contacts or glasses without your
prescription being updated and I'm like
what the [ __ ] do things like a flawed
system what the [ __ ] did I care our
heroes if I'm wearing the wrong
prescription it's the doctor it's like
the doctor doesn't come on after you for
like not taking care of yourself yeah
you know the doctor doesn't look make it
so that you can ever I don't know do
something no it makes sense it's a
little confusing why that would be that
way yeah I hear it's [ __ ] annoying
that's someone with flawless vision well
cuz I don't like to do it I know I know
my prescription why can't I just order
them online and of course everyone
always tweets at me like
oh just order them online don't mock
them they're trying to help you know
they're like they're oversimplifying
sometimes well how do you know there
isn't a system somewhere that isn't
LensCrafters that you can do it online
it's not LensCrafters it's that you need
to get your prescription every what year
or two in order to purchase you need a
glass content maybe you're a vision is
changing that's why okay but I just said
like why the [ __ ] do they care what my
prescription is or what prescriptions
are probably like a law somewhere in
there whether if they give you the wrong
prescriptions they prescribe you the
wrong number prescription they could be
liable for some are totally different
I'm saying if I want to go online and
order some contacts in whatever
prescription I want why can't I do that
what the [ __ ] today I guess you have a
point yeah point like if every day I
wake up and put on some of those
groceries to our reading glasses no one
can stop me no that's true the [ __ ] did
it boy how come you can sell me those
for a story the prescription that I know
that I have yeah I feel you I feel
you're saying anyway I mean I can't
relate I'd type I'm no perfect vision
sure we get it yeah I is the perfect
guys go ahead adobe reader here have an
update it always ask you already know
what it does its updates that's all does
update what adobe nothing who are you he
doesn't even go here he doesn't even go
here okay I got like five left Papa
John's better ingredients better pizza
hail Satan that's funny Papa glass top
of mountains get Dom's good cuz it's
accurate worst ingredients worst Pisa
when Satan um better ingredients better
tip me Papa John's Papa bless all the
most tips but not forgotten
tipped oh my god
Taco Bell where you either get two
packets of hot sauce for 57
I never liked the hot sauce until I
checked [ __ ] tried it and then it's
magical close your mind well in which
it's been [ __ ] months since we had
that [ __ ] who want it okay we should
could talk about ooh
don't double charge me for that we
haven't had like a cheap meal and on all
we've been so good well I started liking
the hot sauce because like Taco Bell has
a surprising number of vegan things that
you can get surprising but it tastes
good with the hot sauce because there's
not as much like happening so like it
needs like a bean burrito or something
yeah it needs a little moisture in there
you know mmm moist oh that's so gross
but like perfect for literally whatever
[ __ ] happens like go [ __ ] kill
someone and drink it we don't care we
make a joke on super bowl for a triple
their song is like perfect for whatever
happens like if we take that literally
we will go commit [ __ ] crazy crimes
and [ __ ] vandalize everything and
maybe murder someone and then drink Bud
Lights whole does the reporter thing
like it's not it's not just suitable for
whatever happened it's perfect it's
perfect you want a [ __ ] grand theft
auto this [ __ ] right now
grab a Bud Light it's it's perfect
perfect why do you think the cupholders
there for the Bud Light I'm sorry okay
Wow Bud Light perfect for whatever
happens after your long day of the
pimping kids but like better have it now
because they don't serve it in jail well
okay Petco where the pets go to pee on
the floor instead of outside I asked you
if you needed to go before we got it
here oh my god I'm so sorry
that's good or by one fish get 10 dead
fish free oh oh you said to buy crickets
yeah
did you a lizard there's no I had a
lizard my sister had a snake so he says
buy crickets we actually used by mice
which is [ __ ] up yeah this is a snake
lives mice um but yes like half the
crickets when we're at home would be
[ __ ] dead in the box like the hell I
got ripped off dude they really five
cents each I want my five cents back for
per dead cricket why am i old breaking a
piece had a ball python
was getting like big she was having to
feed it like small like rabbits and
[ __ ] big she was already like the big
rats yeah and you have to like play with
it so that it
well it's eating so that it wants to eat
it yeah oh my god that just reminded me
of you loved her snake though oh I know
it sneaks on the best my sister a boa
constrictor I loved it was so sweet
they're so sweet um I reminded me of
this subreddit I've discovered recently
and it's [ __ ] hardcore but if you're
in a hardcore [ __ ] go to it it's called
nature is metal there was a there was a
video of this piranha eating this mouse
oh my god like it's basically animal
[ __ ] each other that's probably not
for me it is for me but sometimes I
literally have to turn it off because
it's like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
nature is metal it's called nature's
metal why sure imagine yeah alright
Sherman we use cute bears to advertise
paper for your butthole
oh it's true their ads are cute though I
kind of like what they want you to think
in the end of the day you're buying
paper for your bubble yeah but since
when do bears even use toilet paper I
don't age they just like rub their ass
on a tree they're not very sorry they
should love that when they're standing
against something that's a missus it's
honestly a great way to hit your back if
you stand against something and just rub
your back on it feels so good oh I get
you bears I get you dude that's why
every time I see a bear doing that I
just dab some real quick I'm like dude
[ __ ] you get that edge mmm
Kleenex oh you nasty Kleenex you you
nasty that's funny huh yes you lose the
Kleenex mock my room oh my god oh you
nasty hmm-hmm achoo oh you nasty it's so
cool
everywhere right except at a Funeral no
I'm just gonna say that like you're
crying janessa oh you nasty we are here
to remember oh you nasty my god oh where
where
and now you're being insensitive you
nasty insensitive I'm sorry
how's that I was at I was at a kleenex
sponsored funeral and I didn't like I'm
sorry
Kleenex sponsored Figueroa hey
somebody's got to cover those costs
murals are not cheap that's true it's
true let's not talk about pianos I mean
yeah that was really dark nice sorry
Nike just do it and unless you like
really don't want to do it in that case
just post a picture of yourself doing it
and then like go hug and watch Netflix
or some [ __ ] but get your mom's password
don't pay for that those shoes cost you
way too much
now costed it's costed cause accosted
accosted your Wow
I got a Wow what not funny no it's so
true though not gonna sleep tonight I
have one looks sort of like that yeah no
no I said I have one yeah nothing all
ready said your next one okay go lit New
Balance hey you know we make good stuff
too like just cuz we don't have like
celebrities and set like we need clothes
you make great shoes hey we exist that's
good it should be knew about really that
should be knew about science it should
be New Balance worn by dads everywhere
New Balance hey we exist to new bounds
if you need like a review of our shoes
just ask your dad daddy if you have wide
feet
alright I got it New Balance daddy do
you Nessie Utah I have one more okay
Joey you do a couple does one do you
have more than me Duff major key alert
why is Duff not like printing boxes with
just keys on it some key soap would be
great it's genius and it is Crate and
Barrel congratulations when's the
wedding
good like who really goes to Crate &
Barrel and just shops no it's the
registry spot yeah all right I'll do my
lesson then Bank of America sorry but
like not sorry oh don't get me started
on them they [ __ ] they infuriate me
they'll be like we're like hey we
actually saw this purchase on a gas
station like like maybe 20 feet from
your house but you haven't gone there in
30 minutes
cancel the monocle you get a new one in
five to seven business days if you're
lucky if you're lucky until then good
[ __ ] luck
that's what worse I like member the time
we went to the grocery store and it was
just cancelled on the spot and then I
called them they're like yet did you try
to go to a Ralph's and I'm like I'm just
buying groceries that I shop here like
all the time they're like oh food when
you [ __ ] human you shop thought it
was fraud anyways and the worst part is
like I hear my
who have other banks they're like oh
yeah when I get a suspicious purchase
they literally call me or text me like
okay cool you did not faith America boom
cancelled [ __ ] you so first and then
they charge you if you want to get your
card ships faster yeah I remember I
don't think they do it anymore but the
overdraft fees do you member no no they
do they do that oh yeah I thought that
the someone had won a class action law
so I I got older I got refunded some
money because what they were doing was -
it was wrong i mighta got different feet
in you but they still do over traffic's
like if you if you spent a dollar over
because when I was younger I used to
overdraw like on occasion and then be
[ __ ] because you'd spend one dollar
over what's in here and you could charge
like 15 you're in your current checking
account and you would then get charged
started on which is crazy it was insane
and it wouldn't stop you from
overspending or saying like hey we're
overcharging right now it just lets you
go ya know so if you went to like no I
know I know you ain't got a coffee and
then you went and got a sandwich that
would then be like Oh almost fine $6,100
well I don't know about a hundred
dollars for two purchases but depends
all except the two coffees in which we
know yeah but yeah it's [ __ ] up
there's criminal it's [ __ ] oh did you
have any more yes Snickers we basically
copyrighted hangry oh are you sad cuz
you're hanging no I was making a joke
but you don't even laugh at my jokes now
which joke was an office job Jonna you
know you guys know I win - me I'm not
gonna read them all what is it in the
slogan yeah okay is that the Snickers
one no is it Nike okay I'm not gonna let
you go to the list
it was Pinkberry I can't believe there
are no calories in this Wow they're
walking through the mall you frozen
yogurt and Michael goes I can't believe
there are no calories in this in it and
as it goes nobody said there had no
calories in it right right oh wait no it
was Pam sorry was Pam she's live she
loves it
well thanks for putting up with this
podcast like Jenna has I think she's
given up putting up with it but um oh
I'm sorry what I should go check out his
box
you fellas I fell asleep from laughing
so hard at that reference nice yeah go
check out me ideas go to meet a nice
calm / Jenna Julian for 20% off your
order of the softest and dopest
underwear in the game and go to bull and
branch comm enter product code Jenna
Julian for 20% off the best sheets and
bedding and all other stuff in that you
can get and shipped right to your house
for affordable prices thank you to our
sponsors yeah thank you guys
thanks for hanging out for another week
yeah they think we appreciate you and
always make sure to know that well if
you have an idea tweet let us yeah Jenna
Julian Potter on Twitter because are we
like this week we will find your idea
and make a pocket I will find it I will
read it and we will laugh about it that
is exactly right
oh you guys made me ink Oh can't wait to
find ink see finding Dory ink ink ink
inside of it I know I hope that we still
look alike never new door picture of me
next to Dory we lose that yeah you're
wearing like a blue t-shirt yeah I wanna
be Dory when I grow up be dory 42
Wallaby wait
t-shirt yeah okay anyway thank you guys
for watching and we just don't know
anymore isn't oh I know well you guys
have a great week
thanks for watching yeah bye guys
you